everybody welcome is through coca yeah
my feet look at this great things happen
you play video games thank you for
joining us everybody Beth murasky the
chap over here we got a Jason O'Malley
Jim and Paulo in the back ah put press
koala edge flow alien bots how's
everybody doing Bilal oh oh my god I
don't know how to say that name Bilal oh
good NUI I think I just that's a spell I
just cast on you bet welcome everyone
we're very excited today by we I mean me
we're playing this game Shadow of the
Colossus it's a remaster of PlayStation
4 this is originally a ps2 game came out
right before I while my ps2 got stolen
in college that's depressing so I never
got to play it and I always kind of
wanted to and when here's the problem
though with old games like you hear
about like like half-life for half-life
2 some of the greatest games ever made
uh you go back and play it now it looks
like garbage looks like crap it's all
polygons and you know [ __ ] so they
remaster this game and I can't wait to
play it because everybody loves this
game gold rocket League there you go I
mentioned you congratulations stacks on
stacks hey Nicholas Muni is Conan a real
comedian says McLovin nine one five one
I think that's up for debate you've seen
his monologue six out of ten okay so
this is the most normal shirt I've ever
worn on the stream it's not a joke Braff
dude no flies on you miss Moravsky
someone's a reader of books okay so
we're gonna put a little shout out the
classes I'm very excited and I think the
embargo just lifted yesterday so we can
show anything we want I'm not gonna make
it to the last guy we're probably even
the first guy how many colossi are we
gonna see at least is it colossi or
colossus --is somebody who just said
bereft I've just left you're speechless
alright let's check out the game let's
go to it look at this I'm very excited
damn I missed a lot says Andrews I used
to wear underoos when I was a kid you
know underoos are it's when you're a
child this is actually a very sad story
do you want to hear us
story cuz I you know what guys I've
spent my life in the shadow of the
colossus the colossus being humiliation
enable photo mode okay sure I don't
let's leave it off I don't know
I'm cinemas sure midnight mode aren't we
always in midnight mode confirm fine Oh
guys we just this is what we're doing we
just we just broke open this game so
this is what we're hopefully at least
three colossi says edge flow game
automatically saves your progress I wish
my life saved my progress John see John
says I don't have time for live make it
a 20-minute video you're saying that in
the chat to a live stream here we go
already I love this any game that starts
with a flying Hawk or ego I'm 100% in I
put depressed koala says this game as
the absolute best Oh Aaron aren't we all
assist tell the river shadow of Conan
yeah that's what we all live in man
everyone loves this game this game has
like universal acclaim so it's a it's a
high bar frankly the moon last night was
a super blood blue moon blue blood moon
you missed it so if you think it's
tonight
Globo says where I come from we called
Conan a colossus fair enough we got a
cool blanket already oh
that's a person sorry so far this is
amazing but the best favorite games so
far so far we've got someone with a
sleeping bag with us top three of all
time says weak Jonesy damn baby boy
baller are you cool clearly not bleh
doesn't give away the games he gives
away I sent what are you talking about
Peter Hagan oh that's true I have to
send those people on my own stream I
give away games sometimes and I gave
away a bunch of games I have it sent you
the people yet they're on my desk right
now I have to go back and watch the
stream to see who got what games I'm
terrible classics major do they make any
just missing the controls or grass
mechanics remember that ps/2 controls be
less than great yes they did actually
there's a whole email I got that details
all the improvements and a lot of them
were control based especially with
aiming the bow and all these other
things so somebody's getting my money
already says Duke Nova Nova live love
the view I agree one look at this this
is great a nice summer rain ain't
nothing better than a nice summer rain
you know got an old crazy temple so far
this games starting off with everything
I love birds moons sleeping bags horses
and temples those are my top 5 favorite
things
oh also pizza rolls yeah well not yet
maybe there later in the game I did eat
30 pizza rolls on Saturday I was pretty
excited about it
Leigh is a fraud that's true Madeleine
Sims you guys will get your games don't
worry they're free games you're
complaining about getting free games
look at yourself
oh now wait a second we went from a
desert we went from like a forest into a
desert this is crazy
and we're riding on an aqueduct I never
played the game Gothic Mike Spector what
is it skip lauric we can't skip this
this is the whole thing man
yeah Beth loves this stuff she hates
when I play so the longer we go without
me playing the more Beth loves job
defeat says actually they're complaining
about not getting free games but yeah
you're complaining about oh I'm sorry
it's a it's a it's a gift you're getting
on you're not getting it quickly enough
oh jeez I'm so sad for you
oh it they're coming okay just relax
everybody yeah these graphics are dope I
talk a lot sis Nicole yes that's true
hello that sand guy that's great there
we go
you know what I mean I you know what I
did it if we're done these are the
credits I do hate a game that we're like
the the beginning is like 20 minutes
yeah you know you think yeah this is
cool
oh and we can look around I like this
too this is beautiful
what do we do no all right fine we'll do
normal hard would just be me never
getting it as we all know I'm not pretty
good ah the birds back if you could be
any bird what would you be I don't lie
any because I'll know if you're lying
ha ha ha so tell the truth I'd be one of
those guys that scoops up fish with his
big Oh a pelican Alan oh that's pretty
good like them I like pelicans a lot I
think I like having a bowl in my mouth a
mouthful
yeah mouth full is great for the same
reason I'd like to be like a hamster cuz
you could just keep things near like I
could be eating lunch right now I got a
lot of things on my belt seems magical
bird simulator 2018 a red portal no
we're playing on ps4 the remastered
shadow classes on ps4 right they're
pretty great I hate birds but I be a
penguin Chelsea opticon says I would
like to think that I would be like a
eagle or a bird of prey but I'm
definitely a flightless bird you know
definitely
deaf I was obsessed with penguins and I
was a kid yeah I don't know little from
column a a little from column B no
there's a hot tub in this temple I love
it it's the jacuzzi temple yeah exactly
it's the long-lost I could be any bird
I'd be a quarry
whoo a corgi bird fly it what's a
Pegasus Corgi like a Corky with wings
[Laughter]
classics major says bird simulator 2018
is just Assassin's Creed origins that's
true that's a good point Joe pick would
be the pledging that flies into the
window
well Corgi is's is this a dead body or
like I'm uncomfortable now with what's
going on here
[Music]
yeah I feel like this you know what I
feel like this temple might be showing
us all the Colossus design you know like
this is gonna be like a like the home
base we come back we sit in the hot tub
we look at the other colossi we've
beaten crap
I think I have those jorts I have those
same jorts ved out rouses why is this
segment so bland like white people food
you know it's one people food real bland
that's a pretty big English food is
bland but there's a lot of other white
people on the earth other than English
whoa that's a nice blanket mmm that's
like a $200
[Music]
we're clearly very sad oh it's his
beloved he wants to revive her thank you
Cheetos oh that's not fun oh this is the
avatar font yeah
papyrus papyrus all right one complaint
papyrus Valen turbo Dave says I hope
that's not a hydraulic press we just put
her under that's the danger with old
temples man if you can't read the
language you shouldn't be putting people
in things that look like hydraulic press
is it just me or is that mask getting
bigger
vertigo is that mask getting way bigger
it's getting bigger right press X to pay
respects well play Gingras Lisa's at
Comic Sans they okayed the mask is
definitely getting bigger yeah cuz it
was starting to freak me out a little
bit whenever I go to the dentist and I'm
laying in the chair and I've been to the
dentist in like nine years so it's not
that often I don't want to talk about it
what I'm laying back it the ceiling
feels like it's closing in on me
now is that some kind of a weird mental
thing that was my brain okay it's like
one of those garbage compactor dentists
Oh shadow beasts
here come all my ex-girlfriends out from
the ground why didn't you text me back
I'm sorry I bad text etiquette that was
an inappropriate emoji oh boy here we go
let's do it oh we got a dope-ass sword
you know what these are all my
insecurities you know that shirt doesn't
fit you Oh get away insecurity you eat
too many carbs why did you eat 30 pizza
rolls
I was hungry oh by the way I when I said
the joke about this shirt doesn't fit
you everyone off-camera laugh so I know
that this shirt doesn't fit me the true
it's like the old the old comedy thing
where if you can make the band laugh you
know it's a true joke cabron three says
I'm so mad all of twitch has this game
early no this game is when does it come
out mission sin says Aaron your gamer
you don't have girlfriends correct
called me on that one Nathan Drake would
raid this place in two thousand years
that would actually be kind of cool like
a cool like uncharted Shadow of the
Colossus crossover so if this game is so
widely acclaimed why haven't they made a
sequel to it that's my question
dorming also like i love i would love to
see a game where like an old god or
something just has a name like derek you
know instead of like it's doormen hey
it's Kyle hey Kyle I'll bring back your
soul okay Kyle whatever Oh The Last
Guardian was a spiritual sequel to this
got it
how about just a real sequel why do we
need a spiritual sequel
[Music]
mortals have a lot of bad laws I don't
want to get into it oh I see oh is after
the story that came out first very cool
oh there's no need for a real sequel
says sure he'll sky that will manage to
accomplish what we asked it will need
the if on there Madeleine sim says do
you eat patrols that have like a vacuum
cleaner just sucking them off the plate
no I eat them like a bear eats fish just
like like a hungry hungry hippo I'll see
I knew it
these are the colossi we have to destroy
he needs a sequel skill trees and
crafting system in a season pass I I
wouldn't hate on that what is colossi it
says right there
[Music]
okay so basically we have to defeat all
these colossi and then dormer or Kyle as
I call them yeah well bring our our love
back the soul of our love back here's my
here's my thing have you ever seen or
read Pet Sematary by Stephen King no
okay it's very scary but basically the
idea there is there's a pet cemetery
where if you bury something in it it'll
bring whatever it gets buried there back
to life okay very cool except for the
fact brings them back evil you can't
trust these people you can't trust this
guy I know you need gonna bring her back
sure but like at what cost I asked you
at what cost she's gonna come back as a
zombie see Mary otter and I are on the
same page you're not gonna trust some
giant space god in some temple thing all
right I get it I get it
McLovin you're not blocked from being
viewed in the chat there's just a lot of
people in the shadow right I can't give
you the the single the the love you need
apparently you got to share with
everyone else all right whew dude look
at this how beautiful this game is oh my
god
this is crazy this is gorgeous oh my god
jump off there am I gonna get killed
let's do it and just hurt myself okay
a sunlit place hold up r1 and look to
where the light beam focuses this is
cool
oh this is great
all right so clearly I think also
without seeing the light we should just
go through that giant weird gap
all right that's duck I got a jump I got
oh we got dodge oh come on now Hearst
our horses name is aggro by the way
which is kind of like it's very Papa
Roach or very you know like nu-metal
you know all right let's go how do i all
right horses yeah you know what actually
the horse is kind of realistic to
control it was kind of cool this is Joe
look at how beautiful this game is
okay storybook marry otters Papa wrote
still around I don't know man you tell
me Tom Papa there we go poplar if you
like Papa yeah Papa Roach broke up and
Tom Papa went into stand-up comedy a
lead singer of Papa Roach that would be
on some like like at midnight or
something
Tom Papa Roach like comedian band what's
another one like that like oh my god
what's another what about what is it
Jerry signed no I don't know I got
nothing dad to come out all right
I'm can't even think of any comedians
right now oh wait wait wait what about
we had Jordan temple on last night
Jordan Temple of the dog which was a
supergroup of Chris Cornell and Eddie
Vedder
now Cameron no she just gives you one of
her withering glances don't hurt myself
monster on our world does like dope by
the way Oh turn off the hints all right
um so I feel like I gotta climb up here
right somehow I will say I'm really glad
I waited for this like remastered
version because it's absolutely gorgeous
I just kind of kind of just go but can
you just please just go
all right fine uh uh what about I run up
here right up here and jump nope nothing
okay cool what about can I jump on here
no can't jump on here okay
looking for a lat up can I just can I
just climb the grass Wallace is somebody
okay
oh right you mean this giant obvious
grass wall Beth we're out to hunt
Colossus is okay stuff will eat the
flowers Jesus we've got some Colossus
assesses just to hunt Conan O'Brien
my god that's amazing Conan O'Brien set
some records that's amazing
can I please just use the what the light
oh my god use the light that knows
what's up that's true why don't I put on
some pants Bastian what are you talking
about adjust your set you think my legs
are dark green what the hell is wrong
with you all right okay we gotta get up
here somehow how do we do that can we
get over to this side over here let's
okay how come I can crawl sideways but I
can't just grab onto a Ledge look at
this yeah dude I was trying to do that
oh so we only have a certain amount of
stamina yeah all right so how do I
actually get up here now
yeah it's not
well this remaster is the worst this is
crazy just let me get up there
Oh God
isn't the horse pointing the way yeah a
grouse pointing away you know now I know
I named my horse aggro it doesn't it
looks like I'm wearing pants you guys
grow up alright okay alright let's just
take a stock of this for a second is
there something I'm not doing you
stabbed the wall cuz I'm angry
am I crazy I'm hitting the jump button
go to the left oh there we go
oh whoops then I let go sorry alright
here we go no no that Oh
the grasp indicator doesn't let me hold
it
dragos you're wrong no I'm climbing up
right now here we go alright alright
here we go guys you know I just it's
important I think in every game to
practice your skills alright now I can
jump up there alright well we beat the
calash out of the Colossus everybody
that's right
all of us are the Colossus what if
that's like the lesson and the Colossus
was inside of you all along cool alright
just fell down this thing alright great
uh who wants to see me climb up again on
the vines anyone who wants to see a
stream where all I do is climb up these
vines that's right you blow this is
peter hagen peter hagen hates me so much
he didn't even write out the whole word
you
why are you he couldn't be bothered
alright okay let's jump across here
perfect Wow we got we got good hops
all right try to find fruits to extend
stamina fruits right isn't it just a
fruit all right you would dive roll boom
oh we scared a little birdie all right I
got it now controls are a little floaty
I'll give it up but not terrible get
used to it now we got to do jump
backwards got it all right okay fair
enough
oh yeah oh I think we see a Colossus
assesses oh wow oh oh my god I don't
think holy crap oh my god this thing's
huge and we'd say colossal
oh my god how do we even Jesus God yeah
well here we go let's fight this is
exactly like Conan walking down the hall
by the way and he does Conan does carry
a giant club that he beats us with oh my
god
what do we do
this is crazy dude what are we supposed
to do here just jump on him I feel very
much like his vitals will be revealed
all right oh he's turning around guys
hey what's up oh man I'm real nervous
oh Jesus oh my god wait what oh great
who told me to run towards the Colossus
like an idiot oh I see all right we got
to get on his Jesus God he's got good
aim - all right let's get in there
red Jeff on his foot cool
this is going really well everybody oh
there we go we're on him oh I gotta stab
them in the I'll stab him in the old
back of the calf yes he's a wuss that
was easy
what does this dude eat by the way
whoa this is crazy I'm almost dead by
the way
Klieman today oh I see oh we got to
climb up him grab onto his booty oh you
know what I think I'm here we go yeah
wow that's nice in oh no we're about to
fall off get up there
good now get up on the thing perfect all
right whoo all right now we can take a
quick break this is a great way to get
around this is the coolest lift I've
ever had
there should be like a you know if I
lived in this world I would create an
app or you could call Colossus Colossus
and just get like a ride home
that's how dope would this be like
you're on a date you're like hold on let
me let's go back to my place and this
would definitely be like a clock like a
left XL it's like an uber XL right you
know because you could you could get six
people into this thing no problem
all right now I'm just crawling up to
his head or something this dude I don't
want to be like judgmental of it he
might want to get like his back waxed
you know
all right let's stab them in the head
it's how I do with colossi right the
breeze oh yeah oh yeah there we go
Oh gross oh no there's a shower in this
world miss dude has terrible scalp
oh he's gonna want to use like selsun
blue or something for that oh my god all
his brain juice is coming out on us
[Music]
oh yeah that was cool
all right so we took down one of the
idols oh there it goes Oh Oh No
Oh God oh we're puking and other stuff
is coming out I don't know maybe we got
like some of that stuff in our mouth and
it made us throw up
it can't be sanitary stabbing a colossus
Issus is in the head you know well this
is cool this feels very interstellar I
think we're going into the tesseract
you know we're gonna see Matthew
McConaughey's daughter in about a minute
that colossus is one of the smaller ones
in the game oh my god really
vomit charles says what did that guy
ever do to you besides trying to stomp
you to death and bash you with a club
who's the real monster well me obviously
always uh-oh
she slightly comes back alive I should
feel bad for murdering such a beautiful
innocent Beast you're right cheetahs
Ortiz I should also I love cheetahs and
I love your name
PETA is coming grinch mode I'm not sure
that was blood it looked like a sauce of
some sort like mole a sauce
yeah secret sauce yeah he's like yeah
whatever she said just now she's mostly
dead now she's only like slightly dead
oh my god fourth smallest in the game
good lord
Oh
[Music]
it's just like what I've never played
Pokemon is this kind of what Pokemon is
you go and you destroy them and then you
is this at all like Pokemon catch them
is this like a giant evil Pokemon like
the Colossus like when they were making
this shadow the Kloster like let's make
a Pokemon game where the Pokemon are
huge got a stabbed Pikachu in the head
or something because weird mole a sauce
comes out and the seaside cave it moves
slowly right raised by courage to defeat
it whoo all right
this dude looks like he's looks like
he's laughing whoa video game Vision
Quest this game is so beautiful I'm
playing Last Guardian right now which is
all great but shadow is definitely the
winner Wow God people love this game and
why am I wearing a giant bib am I gonna
eat am I gonna eat like lobster or
something or like nachos yeah crabs
delicious delicious delicious crabs
all right let's we're gonna raise art
now okay so basically this is our kids
before there was GPS you had to hold
your sword up to the light and that's
where it told you where like the nearest
Arby's was you know cuz that's basically
how I use my GPS for take me to the
horsey sauce oh okay
I guess we should get on aggro why don't
we just named our horse rage problems
you know instead of Agra I feel like
it's probably more appropriate all right
let's go
come on horse let's go I not want to go
out this way yeah is this a bet oh I
guess I can't go out this way right
try not go out this way I wanted still
it was telling me to go back this way
it's all out the red ranch sauce mmm
I don't trust ranch sauce it's red thank
you I'm not sure this is the best way do
I raise my sword to find Conan no Conan
finds me after playing The Witcher every
horse is named a roach fair enough
I want to go it where am I going here
I seen rain over me with Adam Sandler
I have not this game is a place that
protagonist finds a center that's cool
unless you're making a joke I don't
understand it's nothing like ranch its
life-changing really I do love me some
RVs well here's how I get down without
dying
Oh
[Music]
you know I don't need these fines and
the masks I don't need all that kind of
just speak like a normal scary
disembodied voice whoa offer a prayer
before it and I wound shall be healed
okay cool all right all right so let's
figure out where we're supposed to go
you're now that we're out of this temple
thing all right nothing no Arby's around
no art it's telling me to go back into
the temple all rights telling me to get
on my horse that's a weird way to get on
a horse but fine all right now where are
we going I'm on the horse still back
this way okay well maybe it's on the
other side of the temple so let's run
around let's go
my horse doesn't not want to cooperate
the ps2 version just think I'll come as
mine would have been if he had this
remastered version ooh this feels very
Lord of the Rings to me doesn't it for
some reason I can't stop looking this
horses butt all right okay oh I see okay
up up okay that way all right all right
hey whoever did that built that bridge
did a good job
come on ah sorry I keep hitting me the
graphics are dope yep
the horse animation is dope this game is
awesome oh god please don't go okay oh
god I'm not good at like this I'm not
I'm really not good at driving this
horse by the way this is also how I
Drive a car so don't ever ride with me
unless you want to be thankful for your
life you know what fight club
when Tyler Durden like threatens that
one guy and he's like that man's meals
well that you know will never taste a
meal as much as that guy tastes the next
meal and he's like he's so happy to be
alive that's how it is every time
someone rides with me in a car
it's just like they just like oh my god
life is so beautiful lizards and fruits
increase your help
Oh lizards and fruits just like real
life that's basically all I subsist on
these days that in protein bars all
right we gotta find a way around this
giant earth - - in an earth in the earth
ah man all right let's go aggro ah I
keep getting this weird camera angle
where I see the horses but I'm trying
not to do that it just naturally goes to
that angle it's not my fault guys you
know what I'm saying it just keeps going
to that hail it's not my fault I think
I'm supposed to be going this way
take me to the RV's agro whoa if you
build your stamina nuf you could grab a
flying hawk and it'll take you to an
easter egg damn son going the right way
does the intern still work for us oh
wait there's a there's a lizard let me
jump off this horse wait hey hey come
back wait what do I do with this lizard
eat it I just killed it
what's the eat which one's the Oh No hey
it disappear except with a tail do you
cook it
oh that's get the horse that's shine
that light I'm just looking for the eat
button which one is the eat button oh
there we go
Dennehy right all right this is good by
the way I gotta say if you're doing
lunges I think you want to go but you
want to put your bolt left foot back
yeah you know he's not getting good
range of motion oh it doesn't do
anything all right fair enough I was so
excited to see that do you see the way I
jumped off that horse though you know I
see it again
now see me jump off this horse it's
really cool cuz I do
oh oh and then the horse hit the wall
like a car all right now the lizard's
around here okay I mean the merry
mercenaire say I love this game there's
a lot of walking am I going the right
way here oh I can't tell because there's
no light ooh wait a second what's
happening here got different kinds of
rocks all right this is like the canyon
run oh here's an old stadium this is
where they had the Olympic Games in 416
BC can I just go into the water I'm
nervous
sometimes water in games kills you and
sometimes it's awesome I'm nervous about
the water rat the Third's arena what
does that mean there's consensus that
we're going okay let's turn all right
let's turn around just let me just
quickly turn Agri around all right come
on aggro I hate to keep kicking like
this but
going the wrong way there pal the 13th
flying guy is gonna be awesome there's a
flying one I can't see anything because
there's no Sun way see this is the
problem before GPS you needed Sun to
shine on your sword I'm in the wrong
area cool
sticks 23 says all right you know I will
say I'm not a big fan of games that were
you okay yeah okay I'm sorry you easily
get lost going back to the beach I want
to kill one more Colossus is's before
this dream is over okay we're back here
all right where we go oh all right okay
I got it
all right okay well we gotta go down we
gotta go down into the pit the party pit
there's a clear skies shout that's cool
oh so it's kind of like a my Dragonborn
in my case is kind of like a Skyrim me
ask thing situation go to a huge bridge
area all right I'm going down then this
is there literally like a troll under a
bridge cuz that's pretty dope all right
oh oh please don't jump off please don't
do that I'm gonna find our way down
there hmm the best way oh wait I see a
okay horse should come to the fray
this horse needs more OnStar I think
this show sucks thanks wave music yeah I
love it thank you for watching a sucky
show you want to watch a non sucky show
our guests tonight are Tom papa roach
who else is on the show tonight Mountain
Joy's the musical guest and they're
already a band so we don't need to make
we don't need to make them a bad cuz
they're already a bit but you know what
we could do we could reverse it so I
will have a Mount Joy Behar nice there
we go thank you thank you
division oh nice
and who's our first guest what I think
Oh Wanda Sykes
oh no that's a bad I can't get the thing
right on the horse all right Wanda Sykes
is their fan with the Sykes will Kapil
such a nostalgic game Conan O'Brien such
an orchestra just not Brian Setzer
Orchestra discontent all right you know
what this game needs more ever stairs or
like an escalator or something you know
how does the Colossus Issa's get out of
the pit it's my question to you should I
just jump off into the water
nekkid survived a fall from this height
I feel like water would be like concrete
ooh this is beautiful down there though
do you think I could just go down those
Falls right do horses float horses float
right I'll die from that fall no because
horses can't go and they're scared to go
with the ring rates yeah fair enough but
we're those special ringwraith horses or
is that just all miss path you know that
was fantasy so you know maybe in real
life horses every game exists I mean it
basically does no wait maybe I should go
over this thing or something now let's
look around I'm seeing a big ramp over
there that I missed which really sucks
for me and for you and for anyone
watching there's a big ramp right there
and we're gonna go on it all right how
do we do this though okay
oh wait the ramps right here ways sword
exactly
we visited the Waze headquarters on our
Israel trip and it was fun okay here we
go another land bridge another day in
hunting the Shadow of the Colossus is
alright here we go here we go yeah we're
not gonna get to the last guy in this
game in the next ten minutes I'm just
spoiler alert everybody if you want to
see the last guy it's not gonna happen
at least on this stream cos colossi
Meriden or is it Colossus assistances oh
wait a second uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh this is
like that scene in Jurassic Park with
the styrofoam cup in the water you know
[Music]
here we go alright
we found the ramp
colossi not Colossus is everyone so
angry I'm calling it Colossus I know
it's colossi dude but guess what's more
fun to say colossi or Colossus and more
fun to say Colossus sissies and you know
what you're not the boss of me so now
[Music]
the Colossus what's the most colossal
thing you've ever seen that in real life
besides my talent at this game which is
pretty stunning yeah now does Montana
have the place where John Ford shot all
those movies what am I thinking of with
the big land that's Wyoming right the
Valley of the Kings is that it scum like
ghost towns ooh you saw a lot of
Colossus ghosts Oh mystery finger says
this game is just all bosses you know
though I that it's like going to a theme
park I don't give a [ __ ] about like the
small rides give me the big roller
coasters you know give me the Colossus
Colossus of roller coasters hmm now see
I think he was underneath I think he's
over here or she I don't know maybe
Colossus is our non-binary Jane Smith
ego Oh shite
it's the kool-aid man oh snap yes whoo
this is perfect oh man that's gonna take
forever to dry wall back up yeah that's
a big man well let's get off the horse
all right we got to shine our light on
him right to see where his vitals are I
don't think how they see vitals all
right let's go it's a big boy oh I got a
oh my god underneath is the leg oh how
do I do that all right
odds are I'm definitely gonna die here
right
[Music]
definitely gonna get underneath is foot
don't I have like darts or something I
can throw this oh do I shoot arrow and
huff I don't have an arrow items yeah
okay cool I have nothing harpoon of
thunder that was pretty cool
[Music]
well there's is but switch weapons how
do you switch oh here we go I got the
boat there we go
all right here we go we got the boat use
the boat let's get that boat let's use
the boat how do we aim the boat
Oh God all right yeah our one like every
elder game ever cut - never no other
game as our one alright
cool that worked great yeah nailed him
oh wow that didn't oh wow he fell right
down alright skip let's get up on it get
out and bro let's go let's get on that
Colossus let's get on the Colossus jump
up on the oh yeah I bet these things
smell terrible by the way oh man this is
you know this game it's kind of in
Turkish I like the fact you only have a
certain amount of stamina because it
makes it incredibly scary climbing up
this thing because you could probably
really hurt yourself if you fall down
hey guys listen it's a public service
announcement if you're gonna climb a
colossus is make sure you wait should I
stab this thing oh you know what I need
to do is switch weapons
[Music]
make sure you use the safety harness or
wear a helmet or something oh here comes
the juice God somebody sauce coming out
of this guy whoo baby got sauce
[Music]
I think we've sauced that's all that's
all we can sauce here let's keep we've
released all the Arby's sauce from the
red ranch sauce from this guy right here
alright where else we go I need to shine
my light on him see his vitals
[Music]
all right
[Music]
now this guy wasn't really trying to
kill me so I kind of feel bad that we're
like you know this guy's sauce yeah I
mean come on man what's the point that
seems pretty mean honestly all right
let's shine our light on him or is it
that it's gonna be the head right now
it's always the head all right where's
that sauce at use our sauce finder it
could be petrol oh boy oh he's trying to
shake us we're getting close to that
sauce you're that sauce bro oh I see the
sauce I've marked the sauce area here we
go
this is gonna be I'd like to say this is
gonna hurt me more that's gonna hurt you
but it's really gonna hurt you way more
all right activate sauce getter awesome
that's a lot of songs
yeah this is gonna suck I felt bad for
this guy honestly what did this colossi
ever do other than break a big stone
wall
he just wrecked years of architecture
it's worth the kill all right fair
enough
you know what he could have oh boy
you're right he could have done that
gently it's awesome oh here we go
already Oh No we fell out oh crap
Oh No Oh we got to get that sauce
there's just a little bit of sauce left
oh man
darn it all right get him in the feet
get him in the feet get him in the feet
I don't like this at all all right shoot
at the ground I do like the fact you
kind of have unlimited arrows though
this is kind of nice the barbecue sauce
colossi a gross dad all the way oh my
god
[Music]
shite
brap here he comes there you go go up go
up to the feet do it I dare you go up
with the feet bro go up with the feet go
up with the feet ready shoot him in the
eye
oh boy I you know what they've done a
good job of making this really scary and
making you feel like the Colossus is
huge all right we got to get on the
other side of this view man
maybe we just run through it man this
guy must really love this girl to do
this I wouldn't do this for anybody not
even myself by the way
all right come on pal shoot him in the
eye I could shoot him in the eye
dang it
[Music]
got him all right here we go
all right sauce quest 2019 is back get
just jump honey get up enough no son of
a [ __ ]
damnit I don't know he's just got the
tiniest bit of Sun do we have enough
sauce in this guy already stab the
eyeball stab the eyeball way too low to
do that
got him alright alright let's go
alright this I should be able to get on
him now come on all right
you would think except I'm really bad at
this game there we go oh boy here we go
we're up
if you're watching at home feel free to
put on G loves my baby got sauce great
song and appropriate for this game and
this Colossus is I just need a quick
rest arou
right here on the old haunches can you
think you feel me on there anything
probably right he knows I'm on him cuz
you know his doom is coming in the form
of my sauce poker
okay Oh oh boy oh I think he definitely
feels me it's like a giant dog oh maybe
this is like the Corgi Colossus I hate
to even bring that up what if one of the
cult all right Beth what if one of the
Colossus is is a Corgi then where does
your where does your if that's where
your allegiance lies all right here we
go here we go we're coming for the sauce
[Music]
ready boom oh here he goes
Oh oh boy Corgi way better than humans I
agree Brian to it ma'am
dunsky actually no one it's more of a
bull it's not a quarry meetings more
like a the last boss is Clifford
confirmed definitely confuses David
pounds oh here comes the Highlander
moment that could be only one and then
I'm just puking and just crapping my
pants that's a weird way to celebrate
the thing now we're in back with
McConaughey and the with tars and the
interstellar tesseract going to see a
young Jessica Chastain shadow of the
Corgi losses that'd be a great mod for
this game too much sauce yeah that's
right yeah exactly exactly that's
hilarious
oh let me go oh I'm just making me feel
bad I don't know man it's like
boom look at us just just 28 artifacts
left and right offer a girl man come on
what are you doing as a clue scaring
myself I love watching streams good luck
what the Colossus is Thank You tae Shima
sixteen different flavors of sauce who
can't wait speaking of sauce I think
we're gonna go eat lunch all this talk
of sauces
has got me super hungry but yes thank
you all for joining us once again the
game is Shadow of the Colossus more shot
of the Colossus is's if you're me and
can't pronounce things the remaster and
ps4 is absolutely beautiful this game
comes out the sixth this game comes out
soon pick it up it's amazing super fun
and so far it's really has lived up high
February 6 that really has lived up to
the hype that everybody loves this game
so thank y'all for joining us make sure
to watch the show tonight we thought Tom
Papa Roach Mountjoy and Wanda Sykes and
we will see you guys all next week see
you later bye
you